[music]
>> Brother Firdous, how much time?
To learn one verse.
Bismillah. As I told you during the
interview that I'm not fluent in Arabic
and that is my problem.
Yeah. So, therefore, when you ask me if
you were to ask me about translation,
inshallah, I can answer you that 12 of
the translation I have memorized. But,
if you ask me
Arabic and translation, I will say no.
So, I will not be able to answer your
questions about how long I will take
to memorize the Arabic.
If you strive hard,
how much time would you take? Tell me,
one verse with the Arabic
and English translation. One verse, only
one verse.
I have memorized surah al-Asr and
uh
maybe other simple verses that I can
memorize.
Yeah. It's just very quick.
Maybe less than If it is a little
difficult, how much time should you
take? Very quick means 1 second?
Five within less than 30 seconds. Less
than 30 seconds? If it is a little
difficult, how much time? Little
difficult?
It depends how frequent I use it. No,
I'm asking you the question. If it is a
little difficult, how much time should
you take?
If you take 30 seconds for easy verse, a
little difficult verse?
Maybe 2 hours.
I could not read Arabic.
And that is my problem.
Reading is different, brother. Yes.
>> Memorizing is different. Yes.
>> that? I'm striving. I'm striving.
>> But, do you know that? Yes. Yes. Reading
is different. Memorizing is different.
>> Yes. You may not
Yes. You may not know
We do not know how to read the letters.
We do not know how to read the English.
But, yet did we not learn the rhymes?
And
And yet we
But, you know, memorizing
If you have to memorize one verse
with the English translation, how much
time would you take?
Well, no definitive. I cannot answer you
this. No definitive, to be frank.
Approximate. I'm not asking you to be
exact. Approximate.
I told you just now, 2 hours, inshallah.
2 hours? Yes.
For memorization, not reading. Yes,
memorization.
Because, you know that I was being
selected only on Monday and I get the
things on Tuesday.
I'm not asking you when you were
selected, brother. I'm asking you the
time you would take to learn one verse,
Arabic with English translation. Yes.
I told you it's 2 hours.
Yes, brother Muhammad Hisham. Can you
better 2 hours or brother Firdous?
As-salamu alaykum. Wa alaykumu s-salam.
To be specific,
just one verse for that day.
Is that your question? Yes. If I have to
give you one verse of the Quran, Arabic
with English translation and the
reference, how much time should you take
to learn that one verse? Inshallah, 15
Inshallah, 15 minutes or less. Masha
Allah.
So, if that's the question, I I believe
brother Firdous can do better with the
Chinese.
>> He's more confident about you.
>> [laughter]
>> But, you are under confident. The the
structure of the question was like a
mildly vague.
Cuz we are all thinking like
>> No, my question wasn't vague. My
question was very specific. One verse of
the Quran, Arabic, English translation
and the reference.
And he said 2 hours.
And you say 15 minutes.
And you say that he can do better than
you. You're more confident about him,
but he is not.
If you cannot read the Quran, if you
cannot read Arabic,
for those of them who are having a
problem
in reading Arabic, you know, some of the
brothers like brother Ibrahim came to me
and I know brother Firdous also came to
me during the breaks and they said they
cannot read Arabic.
You know what is the solution?
Listen to the audio.
Alhamdulillah,
we have the Quranic recitation by the
best of Qaris available free to download
from the Play Store if you have an
Android mobile and the Apple Store if
you have an iPhone.
Download the Quran and listen to the
verses
option
in the application. One of the good
applications that which I know of is
iQuran.
Download this application and put this
verse, suratul baqarah chapter 2 verse
number 111
and put the number of times you want
that verse to be repeated. Five times,
10 times, 20 times.
How much time would it take? Not 2
hours.
If you sincerely give time,
less than 30 minutes, inshallah.
Same verse, just
Same thing.
Listen to the audio.
You know,
and I'm not going to get into that. It's
a debate. And I'm not going to get into
that. It's a debate. You know, when you
come to the debate, inshallah, you will
learn this.
alayhi wasallam also learned the Quran.
Jibreel used to recite the Quran to
Rasul sallallahu alayhi wasallam and
Rasul sallallahu alayhi wasallam used to
memorize it.
This is the way how he learned it.
And this is very much possible.
You don't have to read the Arabic text
to learn the Quran. This is the beauty
of the Quran.
Allah tabaraka wa ta'ala says in suratul
qamar, chapter number 54, in four
different places.
Verse number 17, verse number 22, verse
number 32, verse number 40. Allah
tabaraka wa ta'ala says, "Wa laqad
yassarnal Quran al dhikri
Verily, we have made the Quran easy to
learn.
So, is there anyone who wants to learn?"
Allah is questioning you.
It is the beauty of the Quran
that even
a person who does not know the language
Arabic, his mother tongue may be
Chinese, Japanese, but yet
alhamdulillah, without even
understanding a single word, yet he can
memorize it. This is only with the Quran
and no other book in the world.
This is the beauty of the Quran.
So, those brothers who say that I don't
know how to read,
the jihad is more. I know that.
You may be comparatively spending more
time, but more doesn't mean 10 times
more. Maybe two times more, three times
more. You may be spending three times
more that time than a person who knows
how to read. You may be spending three
times more, not more than that.
But, couldn't you do that for the cause
of Allah subhana wa ta'ala?
Listening to the Quranic verses,
play 10 times, 20 times, 100 times, same
verse.
Wouldn't you be able to learn it,
brother Firdous?
Inshallah, you may be able to learn
because you will be learning directly
from one of the best Qaris, maybe.
Whoever the best Qari whom you think,
Sheikh Saud al-Shuraim,
Sheikh Abdur Rahman al-Sudais,
Sheikh Hudhaify,
whoever you think, whose recitation you
like,
and you can memorize it
and you can memorize it better.
Only one verse.
There are some select
that difficult?
Can you do that?
Can you do that, brother Ibrahim?
Anybody else
on the same boat like brother Firdous
and brother Ibrahim?
Brother Atiq?
Can you do it, inshallah? You have to
listen.
And this is the way how Rasul sallallahu
alayhi wasallam learned the Quran from
Jibreel.
10 times, 20 times, 30 times. One verse.
And Allah has said in the Quran, verily,
Allah has spoken the truth. "Wa laqad
yassarnal Quran al dhikri fa hal min
muddakir."
That verily, Allah has made the Quran
easy to learn, easy to memorize in all
respect.
So, Allah is questioning you.
You people are being questioned.
Are you willing to?
Are you willing to? Allah is questioning
you. I'm asking you a question. Are you
willing to?
Brother Ibrahim?
The rest I hope everyone knows how to
read Arabic. So, there are only three
exceptions.
You want to say something? Yes, please.
Yes, Farik.
So, as far as you are saying regarding
one verse, so it's quite subjective
based on the length. Like one verse can
be one page. So, I think a better
approach from my what I feel would be
rather asking the participants line line
wise so that way because it's very
subjective. If you say one verse, you
can do it in 30 seconds, 45 seconds.
>> I
very well understand that.
Farik, you like Allah here. I very well
understood that.
You know, I just wanted to
let them think out of the box.
I know.
But people have made a mindset. They
come with a mindset. One verse, two
hours, one hour.
They come with a fixed mindset. So, I
want them to change their mindset.
There are verses which I can even learn
in 30 seconds, one minute.
And then he realizes his potential. If I
can learn this in one minute, okay. One
line in one minute. Two lines, two
minutes.
Not two hours.
Three lines, three minutes, four lines,
four minutes.
282, how many lines?
How many lines can it come into?
About 15?
>> 15 lines, 15 minutes if that is the
logic. And that's a lot. Yes.
So, come out of that mindset that
it's very difficult for me to learn.
Either you are speaking the truth or
Allah.
Allah cannot speak a lie. So, that Allah
will not lie.
Allah never speaks a lie.
Allah has told this to the entire human
kind. Whether it be Chinese, whether it
be Japanese, whether it be an
Englishman,
whether he be from USA, whether he
speaks any language in the world, Allah
has revealed this Quran for the entire
human kind and every one of you
should be able to do it. It is not just
specific to the Arabs.
It's for everyone.
And experience
as well as this
as well as statistics have proven that
my shadow
though the people may not be able to
understand the language of the Quran,
but yet Allah will not lie, Allah the
whole fast of the Quran are in millions.
Though they may not be able to
understand it.
They can memorize it.
So, couldn't you memorize one verse?
There are whole fast.
One verse in Arabic, English my shadow
you already know. I'm not talking about
English. I'm talking about the Arabic
portion.
If a person without understanding a word
can memorize the entire Quran cover to
cover,
is it difficult to learn one verse?
The question is how much are you ready
to strive to learn?
One line you had to feel Allah had to be
in the home of Allah. If you strive in
Allah's path, then Allah will open the
path for you.
>> [music]
[music]
>> Allah Allah Allah Allah Allah Allah
Allah Allah Allah Allah Allah Allah
Allah